so Larry this certainly seems
autobiographical so would you just share
with us a little bit of the backstory
and did in fact you lose your dad I did
ten years ago yes it was yeah I went
through it with him about ten years ago
and you know as it was happening you
know the original title for this
screenplay was dying 101 which none of
the other people I'm none of the money
people really liked so we changed it but
I I called it originally called a dying
101 because I really wish that I had
seen or read a book to kind of prepare
me for what I was about to go through I
had no idea really the amount of hours
that you spent in the hospital
the ineptness of the healthcare system
and how the family is fractured and
challenged on a daily daily
minute-to-minute moment-to-moment basis
and then of course there's the business
of death after when you're not even
prepared when you're when you're the
most exhausted you got to start making
preparations to you know do the funeral
so um I just wanted to concentrate on
those two weeks I thought let's make a
movie of just about that I thought there
was enough drama and absurdity and
comedy in that and because I certainly
had I mean most of the things that
happened in this movie happened just
about everything happened effectually
did you end up at a pet cremation yes we
did that's true I don't that was
actually my mother my mother wasn't my
dad but the main crematorium in Towson
broke and there was one in Dundalk and
it had those dual purpose and they
warned us we were like woohoo and we got
there and it was horrible
I was really broken down was a lot worse
than that place and there were pictures
of animals and cats all over the place
but I have proof Wow
that's starting well I think prior to
this film most people would relate to
you as an actor yes so tell us of how
you how you jumped the fence and how did
you tackle doing the screenplay for the
first time well I started writing you
know I started start yeah about about 10
years ago I started writing 2 handers
and the night and now I'm a part of this
uh this cold reading
and we good we work every week and I've
been doing I'm going there for 15 years
where we just read scripts scripts
scripts and eventually I learned how to
start doing multiple characters and
scenes and it was just trial and error
and I really love to the feedback of a
live audience that really helped me
because as an actor I don't know I need
to hear something or feel something or
look forward to that day I'm not a great
kind of sit at home writer just you know
by myself it's torturous actually in
that part of the process is not so much
fun right but then after a while I it
was done and I thought I really had
something
I think dawn in the hands of a less
experienced actress would not have been
as likeable she was you brought so much
texture and nuance and so many layers to
her and can you tell us about sort of
how did you find that how did you find
so much to make Donna fully fully
realized human being I'm not sure she's
likable but she has her moments you know
truthfully I well I relied a ton on
Larry because this is a real person and
he showed me a lot of photographs
initially and and I saw the love that
she had for her husband you know and he
told me about her relationships with the
stepchildren
and then you know I brought my own
imaginings to the character and you know
I I always try to find what is what is
really moving that person and why do
they behave the way they do and you know
I can never accept that they're not
likable or that they're you know bossy
or controlling or whatever she just
needed to have things the way she needed
to have them and I you know I just try
to support what is with a background of
how she is and how she became the way
she did Gallo speaking of versatility
you have a very interesting diverse
background you've shot documentary
shorts commercials documentary shorts
television in addition to features so
how did that diverse background serve
you on this project with Larry yeah it
was it was helpful though I think maybe
the documentary background a bit because
we had such a small crew and not very
short shooting days 15 16 17 days maybe
like a three ton package I think if that
maybe two plus two on crew it was very a
lot of the you know the framing and it
was it was documentary style a bit
there's two cameras shooting the whole
time and the framing would have to be
we'd have to have there's a huge cast
and you know multiple people in cast and
you know just letting it play out and
racking the focus back and forth and
it's really one or two takes no no Larry
I think it was the actors I mean thank
God that this cast with a strong cast
and that was so honored to work with
Bryan and Leslie and Michael Malley and
everybody and Larry and they really just
I think they knew there was only one or
two takes as well and they would bring
it really well and some of it was you
know we lit a lot of it and then a lot
of it was we need this scene
there's some available light here let's
let's try to get it Leslie have you been
directed by a fellow actor before do you
have a lot of experience with somebody
hopping back and forth in front of the
camera Mel Brooks know is obviously an
actor and a brilliant director and you
know it was a huge budgeted movie you
know lots so it's very different but but
in other ways not so different I know I
mean it's really tough on I think the
actor or director you know to go to go
back and forth and lose yourself become
part of the scene again and then step
back out it's difficult would you agree
with that Larry you not me to me that's
the easiest part of that was having fun
I was just I was like I was just having
a black
I mean I mean the actors that I was
working with it was just like oh my god
and then I was just like didn't you know
cover it this is just good coverage
we're gonna be fine
Larry's camera direction yes that's
coverage coverage exactly Tom Arnold
used to always come to me like this on
you man that's all that's not helping
dude a lot of pressure on you man yeah
and I knew that we had good sound I know
an independent really really angers me
when I see ain't not good sound so we
really had to have good sound and so we
had great mixers we had a really good
crew here and because you know an
audience will forgive you for a picture
that's not so great but they won't
forgive you for sound well done all of
you
thank you for sharing it with us